-Welcome back.
-Yeah, thanks for having me.
-Always so great to see you.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-I do want to clear
something up right away.
Sometimes I'm a little unsure
what to call you
when you come out.
-It's Love.
So, it is Love.
-Yes.
-'Cause I heard you changed
your name to Love,
and then I heard you say
it wasn't your name;
it was an alter ego.
-It's an alter ego,
but I did change my name.
I changed my mind about saying
I didn't change my name.
[ Laughter ]
And I have become everything
I've always wanted to be --
Love.
-Okay. That's fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here's the thing.
If I hypothetically --
-Can I see these on you, please?
-Yeah, of course. Happily.
So, how is it? Not bad?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Don't be afraid.
-I won't be afraid.
But hypothetically, let's say
I'm writing you a Christmas card
next year.
I'm afraid
if I address it to Love,
it won't be your name anymore.
[ Laughter ]
-Possibly.
-Okay. Possibly.
Well, as long as the address
is the same.
-I mean, you can call me
Diddy or Puff.
It's just another part
of my alter ego.
And it's me evolving and
having a little bit of fun.
But I'm really
taking it seriously.
It started out as something
I was playing around with,
but, you know, it was something
that I evolved into in my life.
And now I'm fully embracing it.
Why wouldn't I?
Whose name doesn't
want to be Love?
-I agree with you.
"Late night with Love Meyers."
So, tell me about "The Four."
This is an idea you came up with
to have this show.
-No, it was an idea
that came from overseas.
-Okay.
-And Fox picked it up, and they
asked me to be a part of it.
-Great.
-And it is probably the most --
It is not "probably."
It's the most disruptive,
freshest, newest
vocal competition show
that's out there.
It's not a vocal competition.
-Okay.
-It's a vocal battle.
-Oh. That's the difference.
-Yeah, there's a difference.
'Cause there's four seats
that already have four of
the best singers in them.
And somebody from home
can audition by going
to TheFourMusic.com.
We look at their audition.
We have them come.
If they make it past the judges,
which is myself, D.J. Khaled,
Meghan Trainor,
and Charlie Walk,
then they get to challenge.
Challenge!
-Yeah.
-They get to challenge
for a seat.
So that's like a young comedian
coming and walking in here
and saying, "Challenge!"
-Yeah.
That's why I have security.
I don't ever
want that to happen.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-I don't want to be challenged.
And there's some
trash-talking, though.
Do you encourage
the trash-talking
between the young'uns
and the established?
-I definitely encourage passion.
-Mm-hmm.
-I definitely encourage
trash-talking.
-Okay.
-Yes.
-You put together --
-I love trash-talking.
-Yes. It seems to be
something that you enjoy.
Uh, D.J. Khaled -- you convinced
him to do this, yes?
-Yes.
-Did you feel like
when you put this together that
you had to get the right judges?
And how did you convince him
to be one of your judges?
-I mean, for me,
returning back to television,
I wanted to do it in a way
that would give the fans,
you know, more than what
they bargained for.
So I didn't want it to be
all relying on me.
So I wanted to build
a super team.
I took a page
out of LeBron James' --
I mean Dwyane Wade's book.
-Yeah.
-Getting LeBron James.
And I just wanted
to put together a panel
that I felt would be
extremely entertaining.
And I'm-a just let you all know
there's nobody out there
that's more entertaining
than me, Khaled,
Meghan Trainor,
and Charlie Walk.
You have to check it out.
Thursday nights. 8:00 on Fox.
-Perfect. There you go.
-Yeah.